hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the monday morning podcast
know what is it it's time for the
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcast and
i'm just checking in on you
just checking in on you to see how
you're [ __ ]
doing um
i had a great day today i went out and i
got a sandwich
with my lovely wife we went out we got a
couple of sandwiches and as i was
sitting there across the street there
was a
pharmacy see now the ladies are
they're like look at my man sitting
there he's enjoying his sandwich
i don't want that to happen maybe
halfway through his sandwich i could
[ __ ] send him across the street to
pick up a couple of things at the
[ __ ] uh
the right dwayne aide rite aid whatever
the [ __ ] they have out here right
would you mind going across the street
against the paper towels
it's the batteries i was like yeah [ __ ]
it
why not right so um
you know i eat like a [ __ ] animal
anyways right i wolf my sandwich down
and i was just sitting there that's
probably what it was she was just like i
don't want this [ __ ] bald lunatic
staring at me as i'm trying to enjoy my
food so she sent me across the street
so i go across the street all right
and i i pick up the items i come up to
the you know i see all the candy there
and uh bert kreisha i've been doing the
bill burt podcast with him
once a week and uh you know we started
talking about candy bars and all these
obscure ones that i never tried
and he was going to the heath bars to
[ __ ] and i tried it i was like god damn
the heat bar is the [ __ ]
so i was like i'm gonna try a new one
i'm gonna try another new one so i saw a
payday
oh my god [ __ ] it i'll try this payday
right who doesn't like a payday right i
already i already feel like a winner i
got a little bounce in my step
i got this [ __ ] payday right so
i come walking out of the store and
there's this homeless guy there and he
goes excuse me sir can you help me out
with 20
to get a gift visa gift card you know
and i was in a good mood i was like
this be my good deed of the day [ __ ] it
right
take out a 20 bill give it to the guy
and the guy oh god bless you thank you
sir blah blah blah blah and all this
[ __ ] i go there he goes now you can go
get his gift card and go [ __ ] do
whatever he wanted to do and as i'm
walking away another person walked by
and i hear the i hear the same guy go
can you give me twenty dollars to get a
visa gift card
and i so bad wanted to turn around be
like i just gave you 20 bucks
all right you you're [ __ ] over
begging [ __ ] i thought that's all you
needed
but i didn't you know it was an older
guy and i you know what am i gonna
[ __ ] start screaming cutting the
street not like i haven't done that
before but you know i usually do it from
the safety of my car as i drive by
um so i was like all right well you know
maybe he had a bad couple of days or who
knows
when the next time somebody's going to
come by and give him some money he's got
he's got to put his hours in
so i left and i go you know i go over
across the street
my wife's finishing off her sandwich i
tell the story and she starts [ __ ]
laughing her ass off
at me right so i'm laughing too so uh we
had a little more time to kill
and she goes why don't we does the
magazines you know rack across the
street why don't we go [ __ ]
look at some magazines so i'm like great
i'll go over there maybe
hoping against hope that they have a
moto gp
magazine or something about formula one
racing something like that right
because i know all the sports magazines
have nothing to [ __ ] talk about
over here because there's nothing going
on so
i go across the street to go to the
magazine whatever what the [ __ ] do you
call when they just have a wallet
magazine magazine rack what do you call
it
those magazine [ __ ] things there
doohickeys
so i'm going back over to the magazine
thing and i passed the homeless guy
again
and he [ __ ] looks at me he goes
scares me zaggy he gave me 20
for a visa gift card my wife just
bursted out laughing
i hope he didn't think we were laughing
at him in his situation
she didn't laugh loud enough that he
would hear it but it's just like jesus
christ you know
you don't remember me and my baby blue
mask bringing out my eyes i i
am i that forgettable uh
unreal so um by the way that whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] uh i've been watching
you know i'm on facebook i'm an old guy
you know i'm at least
nine generations of social media behind
everybody else everybody's moving on to
tick tock i'm still
wrapping up facebook that's how far
behind i am
um they showed this there was this video
right
of this guy going into a uh a
supermarket
and this he wasn't wearing a mask and
the lady there's going excuse me sir you
have to wear a mask and he just [ __ ]
refused
you know um he looked like me when the
tsa
asked me to do something right cause
there are people out there you know they
just
don't like people telling them what the
[ __ ] to do i am one of those people
right
until people with lab coats start saying
to do the [ __ ] then i go all right all
right
um that's just how i am so anyways he
puts a mask on it has it under his chin
and the lady confronts him again
and he just [ __ ] he loses his [ __ ]
like i've done a million [ __ ] times
and then the security guard comes over
saying you have to he said he wasn't
going to leave to the lady then the
security guard came over so then the guy
[ __ ] leaves
and so anyway the video goes viral
and then this lefty presents it okay
and he's doing the commentating over it
and
all he's doing is just [ __ ] on this
guy who's not wearing a [ __ ] mask
right which is what i've been doing
making fun of [ __ ] people and i just
realized watching him do it this isn't
the way to get people to wear masks
because all they do is just dig it first
of all he immediately assumed that the
guy voted for trump
and they was watching fox news and then
he called him a coward
when the security guy came over it's
like what if when the security guy came
over
you you wouldn't leave the [ __ ] store
and i just kind of realized you know
watching that that i've kind of been
doing that that if you want people to
start wearing [ __ ] masks
[ __ ] all over them is not the way to
do it and uh
just kind of noticed i kind of noticed
i was like ah i think i kind of been
because i was sitting look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] if you want people
wearing masks don't call them cowards
and all of that type of [ __ ]
this is why there's this giant divide
and nobody's listening to the [ __ ]
doctors
um so i actually uh you know as much as
people [ __ ] on facebook i actually
learned something there
um but i think at this point the whole
[ __ ] wearing a mask don't wear a mask
i just think is out the window
it's just become and now people are mask
shaming people
um which i really i hate that whole
shaming suffix that's the new gate like
everything you know
watergate then became iran gate which
became spy gate deflate gate
now it's shame everything's like shame i
think when you're an adult
i think doesn't it if you're really an
adult and you're you're a you're a
fully developed woman or man i mean like
intellectually it takes more than
somebody yelling at you to wear a mask
to bring shame doesn't it match it can
became fat
shaming um all of that [ __ ] um
anyway i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
going with this i just think that where
if we were all gonna get on the same
page on this thing it needed to happen
within three months and now people just
need to [ __ ] go back to work
so i hope they wear masks when they do
it
if not but then i'm trying to be you
know
maybe these people don't like their
grandparents or maybe
maybe you you got an inheritance coming
you know so it's good for you to breathe
on you know
like hey granddad i've always liked you
just get the guy all [ __ ] sick and
next thing you know you get his uh
you get his fortune right i don't
[ __ ] know i don't give i
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore um
i mean i do but i i can't so
uh and i've just been getting into like
i just the vibe of the podcast the way
people are writing in now it's like oh
god am i in this douchey area did i
become that douche i guess i did
i even retweeted these guys wrote a
these couple comics wrote a funny
[ __ ] sketch
wrote this funny sketch saying that
racist people and super people on the
left
super like woke people uh are actually
having a lot of the same arguments and
it was a really smart
[ __ ] comedy joke thing and i thought
was really great and i just wrote
perfect this is [ __ ] great right
and just the amount of [ __ ] that i got
um
like this sketch was gonna like change
things it was like it's just a [ __ ]
joke
it's just a joke i had black people
saying like oh so you think that [ __ ]
the woke movement is racist it's like no
you
[ __ ] morons this is not making fun of
people of color
it's making as far as i understood it it
was making fun of
uh woke people woke white people
all right who are so [ __ ] woke i
don't know
do i really need to [ __ ] explain it
put it this way
one of the people that gave me [ __ ]
about it was a white woman who literally
wrote
about the sketch two white guys talking
about race
enough said and it's like you are
literally the person and then you look
at a profile it says like
spiritual and philosophical
conversations
you know that's who it's making fun of
this person here
who's so [ __ ] woke that she doesn't
realize the irony of her
judging those two people that she
doesn't know
uh based on their skin color and their
sex
is [ __ ] hilarious it's like that's
who they're making fun of so i i don't i
don't i get why it was so [ __ ]
misinterpreted
um i don't know
the way i saw that whole thing if i
remember correctly back about a year ago
woke was something that black people
came up with and it was something that
they
they bestowed on a white person that
[ __ ] understood what they were
talking about
right and then somewhere along the line
a certain group of lefty white people
hijacked the word and then crowned
themselves woke
and started prancing around the [ __ ]
room and i don't know with yoga pants
that said
you know woke on it or some [ __ ] i
thought that that's who the [ __ ] they
were that's how i
interpreted it so i don't [ __ ] know
whatever i'm you know what i'm just
gonna just stay out of all of that [ __ ]
it's just
not because i give a [ __ ] that people
are yelling at me but my job is to make
you laugh
and i'm supposed to be having a good
time and like who would ever [ __ ]
thought that
breaking people's balls about masks and
his stupid [ __ ] sketch i don't know
my wife we got into it the other night
about i don't even know what
oh i remember i know we got into it
about where uh
you know when i go to put my daughter to
bed if i go to put my daughter to bed
it's a 45 minute
thing all right i'm reading like nine
books
we sing the bare necessities she
critiques
my dancing like the bear and tells me
all the part where that i missed
and then when she goes to then we have
to watch the video and then she shows me
the stuff that i missed in the disney
video
and then we she goes to bed then she
tells me to tell her a story
then she says uh i want you to snuggle
with me
it just it just goes on and on and on
and on forever my wife puts her to bed
and it's it the whole thing's over in
about three minutes
um so she's laughing going she has you
wrapped around her finger
and so i was going like well just you
wait
okay because you haven't had my
experience yet she goes what are you
talking about
i said having a kid that you know as a
man to have a daughter
that's just a different thing and now
you
have a son so you're gonna see you're
gonna you watch how your heart your
heart's gonna melt in a different way
and i go but he's not gonna get you as
bad because
you know little girls and women are just
better at like manipulation is basically
what i said and that just
[ __ ] whoa that just [ __ ]
set it off and she goes i don't like
that i don't think i like the way you
said that i go what are you what are you
talking i'm just saying
you know it's just
it's how nature is it's like guys were
we're like
[ __ ] you know trying to rip trees out
of the ground that's what we were good
at
and uh you know picking up heavy [ __ ]
and you guys all right well i can't beat
that guy up so i i got to do
a mental game which is actually a better
game
because you know hitting people is
[ __ ] illegal so like
our strength is illegal so that you're
crushing
the debate here but she didn't take it
that way and everything and then i just
[ __ ]
dug in like a [ __ ] idiot once again
like i dug in with this masked [ __ ] and
i got everybody yelling at me i'm like
all right now that i have my listeners
yelling at me
what can i do in my home life to sustain
this yelling at me right
so it literally got to the point i was
just like yeah you've ever heard the
expression
happy wife happy life and she's like
yeah i go why do you think that is
she goes i don't know maybe a guy wants
to keep his woman like just dancing she
knows what the [ __ ] i was saying
i go why do you think that is
why do you think that is and it just
kept escalating and escalating
and escalating and then ah
and then she came up with you know what
i think he's just been home too long
oh and then i just had to take a [ __ ]
walk after that i've been dropping a lot
of weight at people
just like all right you know what and
with that
i'm going to take a walk i think you've
been home too long oh is that what you
think
am i like am i like do you do you feel
like you have company over when i'm home
in my own
[ __ ] house um but
she's also been cool as [ __ ] you know
it's the ying and the yang here of a
relationship she's also let me
go back to taking [ __ ] lessons flying
again which has been a great thing
um we actually went out and uh
me and my amazing instructor that i have
we went out and we were doing auto
rotations we just simulated
an engine failure and he's teaching me
how to do that thing
where if you're right over the spot
where you want to land basically
how to uh bleed off all your air speed
while keeping your rpms
out of the red you know having that you
know the nauseating sound of the low rpm
horn coming on
and uh like the
what's amazing is and i felt this too
before i started flying helicopters
where people
used to just think if the engine quit
you just fell out of the [ __ ] sky
right and then the rock made a movie
where he was nice enough to say we have
to auto rotate so then people learned
about that but i don't think people
understand the level of control if you
know how to do one
the the things that you can do i mean
you can literally you know
there's 180 autos there's like you can
just
you're like a [ __ ] hummingbird you
can do you can basically do i mean
you're obviou
obviously with what i fly you're
dropping like a [ __ ] stone so it's
not you can make it
to certain places like uh a plane can
which is [ __ ] amazing i'm not
[ __ ] on [ __ ] airplanes either
before i get that [ __ ]
um i'm just saying like
this [ __ ] i'm gonna get down
um i'm gonna just start flying a couple
times a week
and that's all i'm doing is i'm just
gonna be able to [ __ ]
wherever i wanna put it within reason
i'm gonna just i'm gonna get that
[ __ ] down and then i'm gonna get back
to my
uh trying to get my instrument rating
and
i've taken two lessons since i came back
they were just first of all i missed
flying so much but just
the the information that i got and then
how quickly
i improved because my teacher is the
[ __ ]
um i'm really looking forward to that so
my wife has been cool enough to do that
[ __ ] so
you know and basically also know that
you're hearing my side of all of these
arguments with my wife
um so anyway speaking of uh
racing i think i mentioned that earlier
trying to find a magazine they just
don't have that
[ __ ] over here that's one of my favorite
things about being in europe other than
being in europe is uh when i go to a
magazine
rack store i can't i know there's a
different word for it
magazines stand jesus christ my apology
i gotta apologize everybody i apologize
to all my listeners who for the last
[ __ ] 15 minutes i've been going
stan magazine stan um
when you go over there they have they
have all kinds of like in
depth crazy nerd level [ __ ] on
formula one and then to a lesser extent
moto gp
so uh i've been having you know
anyway so mark marquez unfortunately uh
my last
podcast i mentioned how he had a really
bad crash
and i thought he was favoring his wrist
or something like that and i was hoping
that he wasn't hurt and he actually hurt
he broke his humerus i believe second
biggest bone in your body why do they
always say that it's the second biggest
bone in your body what about your skull
isn't that somewhere between your femur
and your humerus
um you know if you actually could
[ __ ] flatten it out you know you like
you know you you take a chicken breast
and you [ __ ] hammer it if you did
that with your skull wouldn't there be
more bone chips
and this is why he would he didn't go
pre-med
um he broke his humerus so he's not
going to be able to race
uh until that's saying he might come
back august
9th so there's a race this weekend
i don't know if there's another one um
let me look up the moto gp thing here
because what i'm hoping is
is that fabio cantararo wins
every race until marc marquez comes back
so he has all of these points because i
feel like a different rider wins each
race the [ __ ] display
the clinic that mark marquez put on on
the last race
like he's gonna catch up too quick i
want the drama
of this guy slowly running down the
field like when i was
basically the um
what i saw in that race him going all
the way back to 15th 16th 17th place and
slowly moving his way all the way back
up to second place
i want to see that over a season um
let's see what we got here
come on man motogp schedule is it that
[ __ ] hard do i really have to
there we go motogp schedule
all right so this weekend they are going
to
no there's only one other race
and then he would be back by august 9.
all right so hopefully i'm rooting for
fabio to win again
and then he and what's his face uh
marquez has it you know
obviously didn't finish and got no
points on the last one
i mean that that could be that could
make this season really exciting
and uh considering it's such a short
season
because i gotta be like i said i gotta
be honest with you the [ __ ]
clinic that this guy put on in the last
race
i mean he's just in a tote like a league
of his own he just [ __ ] passed
i get at the back of the field but he
was passing people that were in third
fourth fifth [ __ ] place
like they were in like 15th 16th place
he just
just blew by all of them i don't know
how he does it um
anyway um
so that's that's like my life right now
i'm waiting for hockey to start up very
excited about that
um i need to work on some of my dance
moves for the bear necessities
and that's basically that's basically
all i got um i got a couple of
announcements here that i do need to
make
uh roast of your teenage self
all things comedy and national lampoon
have collaborated on a podcast called
the roast
of your teenage self that debuted this
week i want to do that show but i'm also
uh afraid to look at
my teenage self uh anyway your teenage
years a tragedy
but that was long ago in roast of your
teenage self
um host alcie morales combines
tragedy and time to get uh to the comedy
of errors that was
your and hers and everyone's teenage
years not everyone's
not everyone's it wasn't everyone's
cause there's always there was the guys
that the [ __ ] guys that they just
knew how to talk to women
from day one from day one
they were just crushing it you know what
i mean they played football they were
good looking they just
they crushed it right at least that was
my perspective anyways whether an
old photo a high school heirloom or an
other
knick-knack associated with adolescent
anguish
and use that as a way in to roast the
unique but somehow universal
tribulations
of being a teen
you know what would be amazing is if she
actually brings somebody on
um maybe i'm romanticizing the cool
person in high school but it really did
seem
that there was a small group of
good-looking
athletic funny popular
everything you wanted to be people that
they just they became they just
they they were crushing it in elementary
as far as like socially
speaking like i think i felt like some
of them their tragedy came
after high school ended and sort of
their fan base
they all leave everybody goes to a
different school
and then it's like [ __ ] man i was the
man
in high school it's almost like you're
like a child star
and this sitcom gets canceled after your
senior year
then you have to go and reestablish
yourself but
i have a good feeling that most of them
as much as the nerds
would like to think that they they
peaked in high school i think most of
them
at least at my grade they all seem like
they did great like
um i went to one of my i don't even know
one of my high school reunions
and uh but i've run into a bunch of
people that i went to high school with
um over the years you know they've moved
all around the country and they've come
out it's always great to see i had a
great great
class of people and and everyone not
only seems to be doing great they all
have really interesting jobs
too so um i don't know
i feel like that's sort of a trope that
someone who was like the high school
quarterback who crushed it
that then they don't do well in life
it's like why would well why wouldn't
they
you know they're they're they have this
magnetism they're gifted
why wouldn't that continue um
i think a lot of like writers out in
hollywood always write it
that you know like if you really look at
all those coming-of-age movies from the
80s
there's always like this [ __ ] nerd
right and then there's the [ __ ] cool
jock who's dating the [ __ ]
cheerleader
and he just treats her like [ __ ]
um to the
and then somehow the [ __ ] nerd does
something heroic
she [ __ ] breaks up with him to go out
with this [ __ ] nerd like that would
ever happen
right like she would risk her [ __ ]
status like at that age you're just too
immature
right you're not you you're [ __ ]
status is everything to you
and uh i gotta be honest with you in my
high school career
you know i really didn't see the jocks
like with the
you know if they were dating a chili
treating them like [ __ ] like
that god that guy didn't exist i feel
like
that was the nerd then went to hollywood
wrote the [ __ ] script how
they wished it happened because they
they were looking at the jock thinking
that he was a dick he wasn't a dick
he could just catch a ball and you
couldn't and you didn't have the
emotional maturity to deal with that
i'm gonna get [ __ ] now for punching down
really bill
you're going to [ __ ] on the nerd in the
coming of age move yeah
i am [ __ ] them all right
i i mean i would hate to see a high
school now they probably let that
[ __ ] nerd be quarterback of the team
just so he doesn't feel bad about
himself
um anyway laughs so roasty
uh of your teenage self um
all thinks comedy national lampoon check
it out check it out
it just came out all right let's do a
couple of ad reads here
um what do we got here honey
we all okay we all shop online and we've
all seen that promo code field taunt us
at checkout but thanks to honey manually
searching for coupon codes is a thing of
the past
honey is the free browser extension that
finds promo codes for you
and automatically applies them to your
cart imagine you're shopping on one of
your favorite sites
note a site where honey uh
there's a typo here directly saved you
money
um well i haven't used it yet
does it work on ebay because i just
bought some old clips for a vintage
new england patriots [ __ ] football
helmet that i got for christmas in the
early 70s
um anyway when you check out you know
what you know you people you shop online
right
you [ __ ] shop online i got to buy
some new light bulbs
i went to [ __ ] home depot they have i
i
you know you know how home depot works
they have what do they have like [ __ ]
58 000 square feet of store and like
three employees
if they they they turn the corner there
is nothing worse than the look on the
face of a [ __ ]
home depot employee walking the floor
they they look like a famous person
that's over being famous
and they don't have any security to keep
like we just [ __ ] come at them like
zombies
where what how are the batteries in man
you like talking over other people
um anyway uh when you check out the
honey button drops down and all you have
to do is click
apply coupons wait a few seconds as
honey scans its database
of all working coupons for that site
watch the prices drop
honey has found its over 17 million
members over 2 billion dollars in
savings
honey supports over 30 000 stores online
example doordash
new egg lulu lemon
lululemon i like that if you don't
already have honey you
you could be straight up missing out on
free money it's literally free
and installs in a few seconds and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid
and supporting this podcast get honey
for free at joinhoney.com that's
joinhoney.com
all right uh here we go tell my wife to
come out here
for the end of the podcast here we're
gonna hang out man
um all right stamps.com
stamps.comstamps.com
uh as we slowly adjust to a new normal
uh we still need to be smart about how
we do business
luckily there's stamps.com to make
things easier thousands of small
business owners have discovered the
benefits of stamps.com in recent months
uh they've been able to keep their
businesses running and avoid the crowds
at the post office
from uh all of their what
am i getting dumber or these sentences
don't make they've been able to keep
their businesses running and avoid the
crowds at the post office
all from their own computers oh that
totally made sense
i swear to god dude there's something
wrong with my brain i posted something
on instagram
i was out getting a [ __ ] ice cream
with my family there
went out to a little frosty freezy
[ __ ] whatever they call them out here
they don't have dairy queens so um i
went out there and they
uh they had a thing that said gp and
and it had the google g and it was all
different colors looked like the rainbow
and my brain said gay pay i was thinking
what the [ __ ] is gay pay
you get like a senior citizen discount
from all the years of people being
homophobic like what's going on here
right
and uh then i oh gp
and my wife explained that's google pay
and i was like all right anyway i'm just
trying to make excuses on why i can't
read out loud paypal maybe you're dumb
with stamps.com you can print postage on
demand and avoid going to the post
office stamps.com also
offers you ups service with discounts up
to 62 percent
and no residual surcharges you've heard
me talk about stamps.com
they've been sponsoring the show for
over seven years now
and if you haven't tried it what are you
waiting for stamps.com brings all
your mailing and shipping services you
need right to your computer in the
comfort of your own home
uh whether you're a small business
sending invoices an online seller
shipping out products or just working
from home you
simply [ __ ] use what am i
simply use what's going on with my
computer here simply use your computer
to print
official u.s postage 24 7 any letter any
package there we go any class of mail
anywhere you want to send
once you your mail is ready just leave
it
for your mail carrier schedule a pickup
or drop it in a mailbox it's that simple
geez they're explaining the whole
[ __ ] process here
uh and when you're done sit down and
have a satisfied look on your face and
like i said with stamps.com you can get
great discounts too
five cents off every stamp and up to 62
percent off you
you usps and ups shipping rate
stamps.com it's a no-brainer saving you
time and money
right now my slash our listeners gets a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
without any long-term commitment just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in bur
burr that's stamps.com enter bur
this [ __ ] laptop better not be dying
on me
every everyone like dies quicker you
know what it is this one i do all the
[ __ ] updates all the time
you know dead steve jobs is loving that
isn't he
um all right that's it all right
everybody hey man you want to wear a
mask
you know wear a mask if you don't don't
wear a mask it's the new punk rock man
you're sticking it to the man man don't
wear a mask
to wear a mask that's a talking point
bro
whatever the [ __ ] that means uh
can we just [ __ ] reopen everything
why don't we just do that just reopen
everything i'm going out of my [ __ ]
mind people i
i have to go back to work okay working
is all i know how to do
other than that i you know i'm just
arguing with my wife i'm talking to
myself i'm going out of my [ __ ] mind
here
can we just reopen the thing i don't
give a [ __ ] okay enough of the
population doesn't give a [ __ ]
so [ __ ] it let's you know
i mean come on that has to make as much
sense
as as the stuff you're thinking right
[Music]
if you think i'm losing it i am i am
losing it i i
need to go on a [ __ ] stage you know
dean del rey posted this [ __ ] picture
of
the lineup at the comedy store
on march 12th the last time you did a
set and i was just like oh my god that
seems like another lifetime ago
so i don't know i want to do one of
these outdoor gigs man
i think i'm gonna do one i'm gonna go to
a [ __ ]
cvs parking lot man in case anybody in
the crowd gets sick or some [ __ ] and
starts coughing we can all run in there
and go buy some [ __ ]
right is that what we do i don't know i
mean i'm so [ __ ] bored
i'm trying candy bars that i've never
never
never wanted to ever try you know
i guess now i'm looking for a no henry
bar that's the bar i remember from way
back in the day
look at me just babbling like this
podcast is over and i'm so [ __ ] bored
and lonely
from not [ __ ] performing oh henry
candy bar
let's see if they still exist
oh henry can you it's a candy bar it
still exists
[ __ ] unbelievable that's like one of
those procedural shows
well you just stop watching it because
you just can't watch it anymore you know
you're recognizing guest stars playing
different criminals like didn't they
already arrest that guy for [ __ ]
flashing his dick in the park
what's he doing now he's got a ponzi
scheme but how long did he go in jail
for the other thing he's got like a
different [ __ ] name
he'd just tap out and then like a decade
goes by and all of a sudden you just
flip it through the channels you [ __ ]
you see all the life has gone left like
the [ __ ] actors eyes they've been on
a one camera [ __ ]
shoot shooting a never-ending movie for
the last [ __ ] 15 years of their lives
um i don't even remember what my point
was
i think that's a good place to end uh
all right that's it oh billy down the
middle i'm gonna write down the middle
again you wear half
a mask right you have it over your mouth
but you breathe out of your [ __ ] nose
you
dope um
[Music]
those people are worse than the people
that don't wear masks you don't wear a
mask i get it you don't believe it
god bless you what the [ __ ] do i know
but to actually put the mask on and then
just have it under your nose
you know what i think about those people
i look at them like they're quitters
you know what i mean like they can't
finish a [ __ ] workout they're too
[ __ ]
fat you know what i mean or they just
got [ __ ] horrific breath and they
finally realized that i have no idea all
right i'm babbling
i'm like this comic that's trying to end
on a laugh and just doesn't have the
[ __ ] joke and he's just gonna keep
going
he's just gonna keep going um all right
enjoy the music
enjoy this uh throwback uh
thursday afternoon just before friday
monday morning podcasts from
a i don't know a couple years ago and a
little bit of music
always picked by the wonderful andrew
themless all right i'll see
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
july 23rd
2012. here's my little sesame street
moment um today's show is brought to you
by
audible please visit audiblepodcast.com
bill for your free audiobook download
you like that wasn't that just like
sesame street today's show
is brought to you by the letter l and
the number five
and they'd be playing that harmonica
remember that the outro music
how the [ __ ] did i used to know how that
went
i don't [ __ ] know um well you should
probably ask yourself at this point what
is audible.com
it's basically it's for people who like
to read books but don't like
to read you know you ever get sick of
your eye going from left to right left
right
or your eyes if you're not wearing a
patch you know people do you want to
read a book but like don't want to read
it
wouldn't it be nice if you know if you
had someone
who could just read it for you go to
audiblepodcast.com
bill and you can uh any book you want
i'm a big irvin welsh fan the acid house
i like that one
you know you could read that one if you
wanted or not really
and then you go to a party and say you
read it you know
it's kind of like fake credentials
except in like a book sense
audiblepodcast.com bill for your free
audiobook
download come on when you're driving to
work
just have them read all the classics to
you and then you'll actually seem like
you're well read and you're not it's
perfect
you don't need to read a map anymore you
just have that broad in your car going
make a left in seven seconds right
now you can just have some guy reading
the book once upon a time in a galaxy
far
far away they'll live these people you
[ __ ] nerd
um all right this is the monday morning
podcast for you people this
was a brutal brutal brutal not
funny [ __ ] week in the world you know
as opposed to what bill all the
happy-go-lucky you know
weeks in the world you know what i'm
talking about
very tragic tragic [ __ ] week and
today i woke i woke up to more tragedy
or the ending of uh tragedy uh paul
verzi v-i-r-z-i for you people trying to
find him on twitter
versi v-i-r-z-i dude i called it what'd
i say
um he called me up
he texted me he goes dude are you
washing you watching this they're
cleaning house
epic cleaning house and i thought he was
talking about the red sox
you know what i mean which by the way
i'm in boston right now and i don't
understand
why the [ __ ] everybody's so down on the
red sox they're 48 and 48 they're 500
they're three and a half games out of
second place
who gives a [ __ ] you know it's the ebb
and flow of life they want two world
series now they're going through a low
point
you know why are you acting like in your
own life you make the playoffs every
year
you hold up the championship you know
and they ask you you know hey what's it
uh you know what's it like to be a
championship what do you got to say
about
finally winning the championship and
then you go it's about that time
[Music]
[Laughter]
that might have been the worst just
winning a championship quote ever lebron
james
james brought you king james you're
probably well what do you have to bow
down
well why didn't you just go you know i
just want to thank my teammates and the
fans for being supportive
you know it's just it's an unbelievable
like words you can't put into words just
something like that so
it's about to have time you know
i don't know his stupid [ __ ] agent is
probably gonna try to trademark that and
just start having him say that in every
stupid commercial
you know advertising toasters toast pops
up it's about dab dab
um cut lebron you know when you're
saying it's about damn time
it seems like you're saying that the
toaster takes too long
to toast the bread you know
okay no i'm not saying that he has i i
wasn't aware i couldn't talk to him i'm
sorry
who are you white guy in a suit okay all
right
okay well we'll fix it in the editing oh
jesus
um yeah it's just a brutal [ __ ]
brutal [ __ ] day brutal [ __ ] week
not a lot of funny [ __ ] where the [ __ ]
is my phone buzzing right now
hang on a second ah [ __ ] that phone
[ __ ] that phone in its ass you know what
speaking of just brutal you know i had
one of the worst
nightmares i've had in forever
last night alright i'm laying in a hotel
room here and right now you should ask
yourself bill it's monday you're usually
home or you're flying back from some god
forsaken place why are you on the road
why are you in boston you want vacation
dude what are you doing
you're taking a booze cruise um
i am actually i booked some acting work
to be honest with you
um i'm shooting a pilot out here they
are redoing the kids show zoom
from back in the day they're going to do
a reboot and uh i booked the gig
you know i'd like to think it was
because of my acting ability but i think
it was because i remembered the jingle
from way back in the day right
zoom z double o m box three five o
boston mass o
two one three four sent it to zoom
and i pointed right at the cast director
right casting director
sent it to zoom and i on the zoom i took
it out right like a [ __ ]
gun and they were just like wow this
kid's got the fire
we got to hire him get him in a striped
shirt
did anybody used to watch that so zoom i
think it was a very like local boston
show where it was just these
burn out [ __ ] kids you ever seen a
kid like five years old and he already
looks like he's got a coke problem
that's what like
zoom was
and they're doing a reboot they're
rebooting it up
you know i had an idea to do a prequel
to my
my i i have three stand-up specials i
got one more coming out in october right
so i got
three you know so that would be my star
wars empire strikes back
and [ __ ] return of the jedi so now i
should do like a prequel
okay i should [ __ ] grow my hair out
what's left of it and get like a [ __ ]
red wig to put on top have like a gabe
kaplan
afro and just go out there and do like
topical humor
from like i don't know 1982
you know go out there whale doing some
bad ronald reagan impression and i
figured you know what that'd be funny
for about 20 seconds then what do you do
for the other [ __ ]
59 minutes 40 seconds and there there
goes that you know what i should just do
a trailer
a prequel ah jesus who gives a [ __ ]
um anyways anyways
uh it's just just been a brutal week so
i turn on the tv to see what verse he's
talking about
what he was talking about and it's um
no wait let me get back to the red sox
here before i get into that [ __ ] uh
i'm all right with the red sox sucking i
actually like them more now
that they're not doing well you know
i don't this this is when this is when
you see who the real fans are
and who aren't they there's people dude
[ __ ] you [ __ ] redshirt
those guys bandwagon bandwagon you
bought your first hat
after game seven of 2004 oh maybe game
five
you know you [ __ ] break with your
green monster tickets you [ __ ]
sit down in the bleachers like the rest
of us those [ __ ] awful blue seats
remember i used to go to games right
there'd be nobody [ __ ] there just
baseball fans before espn ruined it
and just so inundated the maybe it's we
just like
out [ __ ] our stadiums i don't know
what it is there's so many goddamn
people now
i remember back in the day you'd go to a
game you know just having a good [ __ ]
time
and there'd always be some guy and he'd
have there'd be an empty seat on either
side of them
and that's how we get that you know you
know let's go
sox thing going he would just slam both
chairs down
you know the this because they're fold
up chairs right
jesus bill can you paint a better
picture here you're losing us
you'd be slamming both of them down and
everybody be hammered and you know
there'd be maybe five people there
who had like some sort of like red sox
actual
jersey on other than that you had a hat
you just [ __ ] jesus they're counting
down something out there
i'm near the water any of the water
[ __ ] coast guard um
yeah like you'd have a red sox hat that
was it and he had the piece of [ __ ] one
the one size fits all
you didn't have like the same one that
clemens was wearing
and you know and now you go to the
goddamn games it's like people did
they're [ __ ] wearing the whole damn
thing
everybody's walking around they look
like managers
you know like bullpen like there's like
they should be in the bullpen
so i like it i like that they suck i
like that they're trailing off i like
that i'm starting to see
uh some empty seats it's bringing me
back
you know if they could just stop singing
that [ __ ] song
during the seventh inning stretching if
they could just get rid of that stupid
[ __ ] mascot all right
i understand why you're doing it for a
marketing reason
i totally get that to try to get kids
hooked into the game why don't you you
know
you know i got into the game i went to
the game and i enjoyed [ __ ] watching
the game
that's it i went there and i was sold
the second i walked in there
i didn't need some big [ __ ] muppet
coming up to me in some creepy way
and but it's like you know you cut its
tongue out so it can't talk to me
i [ __ ] hate that about mascots i hate
how they won't talk to you when you go
hey what's up man and then they do that
real [ __ ] hyper nod
it's like i know there's a guy in there
you idiot there's no [ __ ] kids around
you can't give me a man what's going on
it's [ __ ] hard as [ __ ] here
all right man oh here comes some kids i
gotta shut up you know can't do that
i mean how much are they really paying
you a game
all right so anyways versi was talking
about uh
he was talking about penn state like all
those sanctions against penn state dude
it's
[ __ ] brutal like i i don't i don't
think that the
the punishment is in the right area
i don't get it why are you punishing the
players and the fans
you're acting like they look the why do
the wins don't count from 2000
from 1998 to 2011 why don't those games
count
he won those [ __ ] games you know what
i mean
that would be like if if [ __ ] i don't
know
if mark sanchez gets arrested for
drinking and driving
right does his you know if they beat the
the dolphins the week before does it not
count what the [ __ ] does drinking and
driving have to do
with whether you know you beat the
dolphins or not
i don't i don't get that like so now all
these players that played for penn state
who now sit around probably get together
every couple of years for a union
remember that time we played clemson you
know sitting there with a cigar and
scarred up knees
they want to tell war story oh yeah that
doesn't count anymore
why because somebody [ __ ] a kid
i didn't you didn't nobody played the
game did nobody did
you act like it happened during the game
and they played the game around the
crime i mean it's a [ __ ] horrible
crime but i
i think what they're trying to do is
just erase
joe paterno's name off of any all-time
list they don't want his name up there
you know what i mean
and um i i don't know i just don't think
it's
it's uh i don't think that that's right
i think that those victories should
count
he [ __ ] won those games that doesn't
make any sense
what the [ __ ] is going out there on
outside you know what right out the
window they got a couple of coast guard
things
and there's probably some [ __ ] idiots
went out on a goddamn dinghy every year
some stupid [ __ ] kids do that right
and they have the stupid uh memorial
little stevie sharipa and uh mike uh
merkin wits you know they always got to
do that [ __ ] and just have some sort of
like uh whenever there's a tragedy you
gotta have some sort of like metaphor
you know water is uh it's the liquid of
life
when uh stevie shirepa and uh mike
markowitz went out of there digging
uh they didn't realize that that uh
life nectar could also be uh
i've really talked myself in the corner
here haven't i oh they [ __ ] drought
and uh we found the raft
that would be the worst doing that um
i don't know dude it's just been a
brutal [ __ ] week i feel bad for
penn state players i feel bad for their
fans because i feel like they're getting
punished too and they didn't do a
[ __ ]
thing okay it's a great [ __ ] football
program
and it's [ __ ] i can't even wrap my
head around that joe paterno was
involved in that i mean this is the
biggest sports mind [ __ ] since o.j
simpson
you understand oj to me was it was the
juice
2 000 yards in a 14-game season
um those hertz rental car commercials
monday night football
i even watched his bad movies like when
he played that astronaut it didn't make
it to the moon and then they tried to
kill him
you know and the two white astronauts
coast they killed oj because that's how
it always worked back then if you watch
any def jam comedy they'll let you know
the black guy always died in those
movies
right through the naked gun and then out
of nowhere he's on trial for a [ __ ]
double murder
and he's got a look on his face like yes
i did this [ __ ] how do i get out of this
um this is the biggest i think mine as
far as like who you
thought somebody was and then what the
[ __ ] they were involved in
it's just brutal and there's nothing
funny about it so let's move on
let's [ __ ] move on um
all right let's continue with the sports
uh as of right now dwight howard isn't a
laker but if dwight howard goes to the
lakers
you know and kobe wins his sixth
championship
i am not going to engage in that
argument that he's now equalled
michael jordan anybody who comes up to
me i
as you s comes out of your mouth i'm
gonna kick you right in the balls
all right look you know how there's this
steroid error in baseball
there has to be the pylon error you got
to put that in there
okay michael jordan won six
championships
with bill cartwright and luke longley as
his [ __ ]
centers how long do you think kobe
bryant would tolerate that
before he demanded a trade
okay this guy won three championships
with shaquille he got shaquille o'neal
and phil jackson he got them brought to
his team and i don't think well michael
jordan had phil
jackson phil jackson was nobody
he became a legend coaching michael
jordan
okay and i'm not taking anything away
from this guy but when the bulls got him
it wasn't like oh they got phil
jackson this guy knows how to win he was
nobody he was an ex
nick who won it in 73 as a player that
was it
he came in with his hey me and [ __ ]
afro and mustache
that was it okay and chicago
was rebuilding oh they had scottie
pippen he came from their system
all right they signed dennis rodman
one [ __ ] guy okay
they won with [ __ ] bill cartwright
luke longley
bj armstrong that mormon with the blonde
hair
okay before jordan came along
it was considered impossible to win
without a [ __ ] big name center
you had to get a big name center you had
to okay
the guy totally changed the [ __ ] game
and i'm so sick of these
[ __ ] bean counters who go well he has
six championships and he has five
therefore if he gets one world
championship it is the same thing
it's like all these people who watched
uh whoever the [ __ ] it was break dan
marino's passing record and they don't
even look at the fact
of of all the passing rules changes
i mean they say that hitting a curveball
is the toughest thing in sports i think
at this point covering a receiver is
because you've basically
essentially made it illegal past five
yards
down the [ __ ] field oh jesus he's on
his soapbox
he's on his soapbox all right so now if
dwight howard
goes to the [ __ ] lakers it's just
like
i i don't get i tweeted about this like
the amount of [ __ ] that the miami heat
got for having a pylon championship
kobe bryant has been part of a pile on
[ __ ] team from about 1999 on
that's all i'm saying okay
and i know what you're thinking well
boston did it in 2008 yes they did that
was a pylon championship team
i don't look at that team like that's
like the 86 celtics or the 84 team i
don't
okay i i wasn't a fan
of what when what happened there either
you know
but doing it once versus doing it every
year for 15 [ __ ] years
you mean you know you're making a pile
on team when like the nba steps in and
blocks a [ __ ] trade
you know when even they're sitting there
going like all right guys this is
getting a little [ __ ] ridiculous
don't you think
you know what i mean i'll get a ton of
[ __ ] for that too all right let's just
let's just get it let's just read
christ i'm all over the goddamn map here
let's just read something advice here
advice uh 37 and at the end of the love
road
jesus christ i thought we were going to
pull out of the [ __ ] dirt here hey
bill i'm 37 years old and i've never had
sex with a
woman i've been in love with oh i
thought you said you never had sex i was
just gonna be like all right dude that's
a wrap
that dream is over or just go out and
get yourself a hooker
all right and like the thickest [ __ ]
condom ever
um anyways i'm 37 years old and i've
never had sex with a woman don't you
hate on these [ __ ] macs when just
some application just keeps why is it
just keep bouncing up and down i see you
it's like the [ __ ] nerd in the back
of the class oh i know the answer i know
the answer
um i'm 37 years old and i've never had a
i've never had sex with a woman i've
been in love with or liked
strongly i've fallen in love with many
beautiful young women over my long run
but my deduction is that i become a
total social [ __ ]
with those chemicals when those
chemicals are coursing through me
if i chase a girl
if i chase a girl she's turned off when
i'm indifferent i do all right
that basically means you're coming on
too strong dude it's like a burner turn
down the gas a little
you know are you showing up with like
[ __ ]
and candy with your hair parted down the
middle the first [ __ ] day yeah you're
gonna freak her out
um anyways when i'm indifferent i do all
right i've kicked a number of women out
of my bed
and life after they've made the smallest
infraction one girl had the greatest
sense of humor
and had a perfect athletic body i threw
i threw her out one night because she
was eating chicken wings in my bed
only because i didn't have that am what
only because i didn't have that emotion
that made me want to chase her down
or keep her otherwise i think she was
great
you broke up with a girl because he was
eating chicken wings in bed
that was your lock the door test um
of course now i get that love feeling
less and less frequently as i get older
and my failure to grow mature with the
woman over the years has given me
an anthony kumia complex i only want
young fit
chicks but now after years of living
with a void in my social life and being
daily devoted to girls
of the internet i finally fell for
another real girl a young profession
personal trainer
who joined my beach volleyball team oh
[ __ ] you
with your hot ass oh jesus look at this
[ __ ] guy he probably looks like uh
[ __ ] james bond
the other chick on our team tried to
convince me that this new girl was
interested in me oh yeah all these
chicks trying to help you out what if
she was blowing you
uh the new girl was showing signs of
flirtation but when i made a move
she fell silent i am an old man my
question to you is
since handguns are illegal and very hard
to find outside of the urban areas of my
country of canada
should i get a slingshot and shoot
myself over and over in the head with
acorns until i'm dead
or at least until i am particularly i am
less particular about
what kind of vagina falls onto my [ __ ]
um yeah dude you got you gotta you gotta
make a pick here
you're 37 years old you're drafting in
the later rounds you're still trying to
pick up a blue chip it ain't there right
i don't know what to tell you
you can take a risk on one but you know
i think uh yeah
i think you got to look at the douchey
qualities of yourself
and realize that they're putting up with
you and whatever the [ __ ] it is that you
do
you know um you're only 37 years old
fortunately that's still young back in
the day you know ben franklin's day
you'd look like you were 106 and it
would be over and you'd have [ __ ]
tuberculosis
you know wheezing that you never [ __ ]
found love so you're fine you're playing
volleyball you just sound like an
in-shape guy who keeps banging all these
hotties but
woe is me can't find love you know what
go [ __ ] yourself in your awesome life
huh you can't find love and you're all
[ __ ] you just oh i just keep [ __ ]
one personal
22 year old personal trainer after
another this is a problem
look if you want to find love i i would
uh
i would stay single until you found it
you know i think you like women just
being infatuated with you and playing
with your hair and telling you how
amazing you are as you're going no
no no no and then he keeps saying yeah
look at you
you're not that old you still have four
abs
right i think you like all of that i
think you like that [ __ ] attention i
saw a guy like that this weekend right
he's hanging out with the lovely nia we
went to this mexican restaurant
and this guy shows up right dressed like
arnold schwarzenegger
and when he lost a little bit of weight
and he was promoting terminator 2
on arsenio hall and he came out in that
leather ensemble
uh that's how the guy was dressed and he
comes in with this absolutely [ __ ]
smoking i don't know brazilian
armenian iranian i don't know what the
[ __ ] she was
[ __ ] smoking hot chick with like this
lime green i don't
even know what i didn't know what the
[ __ ] she was wearing
it like you know showed like her [ __ ]
flat stomach
her [ __ ] round ass yeah i was
checking i think it's one of those girls
you can check out right in front of your
girlfriend she doesn't give a [ __ ]
you know she's like checking her out too
like god damn that [ __ ] is hot
um so the bartender cards
the guy which he absolutely loves
because he thinks it means that he
thinks that he's [ __ ] 21
you know the guy looked like he was 50
and he just goes he's like my friend he
goes
how old do you think i am he has this
big cheesy
date rape smile with his awful [ __ ]
beard
and he's just like how old do you think
i am right and the guy goes i don't know
35 right and then nia goes like [ __ ]
like
you know like goes makes this gesture of
like way higher wait i [ __ ] burst it
out laughing but i don't think the guy
saw because he was so full of him like
he actually
didn't realize that this kid was just
working for his tip it's like dude you
look like you're 50 and he goes
i'm from he's like i'm 48. you seem like
one of those guys
like you're out there hooking up with
them so uh i would say stop being such a
self-involved douchebag
and realize that you have faults
yourself
get over yourself all right
you're actually starting to because
you're really because you're starting to
slip into those uh
i'm not you know you're in your david
hasselhoff years who's kidding who
but you know if you're gonna be in those
years and you haven't found love you're
doing it the best way ever
banging personal trainers and uh
volleyball players
um anyways that's that's the picture
that you you painted yourself you could
be a tub of [ __ ]
because you are playing volleyball in
canada i mean i don't know
how many weeks a year you can do that up
there i can't tell
this like the picture that you painted
is who you really
are or if you're an even bigger psycho
and you actually don't look like that
but that's how you you picture yourself
um yeah i would my advice would be get
over yourself and realize that um
you know i don't yeah i've talked myself
into circles i have no [ __ ] idea
oh do you know i ruined a woman's day at
the mall i just remember that this woman
in a wheelchair
i ruined a woman an old woman in a
wheelchair's day
at the mall and it's been killing me for
like the last two days
is what happened me and me we were
leaving the mall
the mole okay and we wait for the
elevator to open the elevator opens and
all you see is this beautiful babies
that's the first thing you see when the
doors open is this baby laying in a s
in a stroller looking up big blue eyes
one of those
gerber looking babies right and me and
me and both go oh the second we see
we're like how you doing you know
talking like baby talk to it and saying
the mother how good
looking the kid is and all that type of
[ __ ] and with goo gone
about the [ __ ] baby and she gets off
the doors open
when the doors open the first thing we
see is this old lady in a wheelchair
being pushed by some lady and you know
they back up and the woman with the baby
uh gets off the elevator and then
the woman starts pushing the old lady in
to the elevator and she's going is this
going up
is it going up i'm going it's going down
and it's one of those things there's
like tension because the doors are
starting to close so even though i keep
saying it's going down
the lady's not hearing me because all
she's focusing on is the door she says
is this going up is it going up it's
going down it's going and i finally go
it's going down
like i yelled over the [ __ ] old
lady's head so the old lady looks up
she just goes oh okay thank you and i
totally knew in that moment that she was
just like you were talking to her like i
wasn't even here
you didn't even acknowledge that i was
here
and i realized it in that moment and i
don't know why i think it was because i
was talking to a baby i was still i s
and she was like fragile too my brain
went back to talking to the baby
and i just looked at it and i went as
the doors were closing i was doing
okay bye bye i said it just like that
and i waved to her like she was a baby
i don't know why i did it and then the
doors closed and i immediately
immediately looked down at the floor in
shame
and nia was one of the hardest i ever
heard her laugh she just
turned around and faced the back of the
elevator
and was laughing to the point she
couldn't even like get the words out to
ask me
why i just did that she kept just going
like like she just kept getting out the
y
part and i just kept going i don't know
i don't know why i just did that i
stuck my hand out right in her face you
know you waved to a baby
i did that i went okay bye bye
doors closed and i know she was probably
thinking either i was
mocking her or that i felt that she
wasn't
mentally there anymore and i knew that
she was and i just feel like [ __ ]
and um the reality is i could have
ridden the elevator back up and tried to
explain myself
but i didn't i just walked in shame to
my prius
um yeah it was just a [ __ ] weird week
the whole [ __ ] week was just weird i
had one of the worst nightmares
i've ever had in my life last night i
was i'm laying in bed it's one of those
dreams where like there's something
trying to get me but it's like
it's like sort of inv it's like a force
it's trying to get me i know it's going
to get me
and i can't fight it or get away from it
i'm just like
even like the dream i'm like laying in
bed and i can't [ __ ] move
and then in the end all of a sudden this
[ __ ]
woman appears like just kind of like
like a ghost but it looks like a person
right
and uh i have my hands clasped together
and she's like
she had like [ __ ] uh like reddish
hair
but like you know like when hot chicks
dye their hair red they're not real
redheads
like that like almost like a [ __ ]
i don't know like a page boy kind of
haircut
she was like a rocker chick she had
tattoos and like this tank top on nice
titties
and i'm sitting there i have my hands
clasped and she clasped her hands around
my hands
and she looked me right in the eye and
goes you're gonna kill yourself one day
and then she just disappeared and it
[ __ ]
freaked me out obviously she goes you're
going to kill yourself one day
with this look on her face like either
she knew
or she definitely knew and that she had
killed herself and i was going to join
her wherever the [ __ ] she is
in the afterlife and uh
i was so [ __ ] scared it actually woke
me up and i wouldn't open my eyes
because i also be afraid that she was
gonna be standing there
waiting to clasp my [ __ ] hands again
how freaky is that now let me ask you
this because
you know i think about killing myself
but i do it in a very mainstream [ __ ]
way
like you know okay bye-bye when the door
is closed i wanted to kill myself i
wanted the elevator to land on me but i
don't really want to kill myself
so what the [ __ ] does that dream mean
anybody
wants the deal
um and i don't believe in ghosts either
i think the reason why i had that dream
was because last night i turned out all
the lights
and i and i got a little freaked out
because uh my
room right is right near the water and
there was this really weird reflection
and i had some weird shadows and stuff
so what i always
do when i get freaked out like that is
this is the stupidest thing ever
is i give the finger to the shadow
that's what i do
it's something i learned when i was a
kid because if it is a monster it's not
going to put up with that
right it's immediately going to come
over and do something to me so if i give
it the finger
and it doesn't do anything that when i
was a kid it just let me know that it
wasn't a monster
or that it was a [ __ ] [ __ ] and it
wasn't it didn't have it in it
you know it didn't have that killer
instinct and it was just gonna it was
just gonna
uh just stay over there in the corner
which i was fine with
you know you can spend the night just
don't come over and kill me that was
basically it
so i did that i still do it to this day
and i i do it it kind of is a joke
and it makes me laugh for some reason i
was thinking about that chick in the
ring just with their [ __ ] hair
popping up and doing something to me
you ever do that you just mind [ __ ]
yourself and i was like alright i have
10 seconds to get into the bed
or that chick from the ring is going to
appear and [ __ ] kill me
you know so i got myself in this anxious
state i think before i went to sleep and
then i ended up having this goddamn
nightmare and she [ __ ] clasped both
my hands and goes you can
you're gonna kill yourself one day
[Music]
[Laughter]
and i just sat there laying there i'm
not gonna kill myself
don't open your eyes that freak you out
well what gives a [ __ ] it's been a weird
[ __ ] week
you know that awful tragedy out there in
uh
colorado you know i was driving in my
truck all i have is [ __ ] uh am radio
and um
and so all i could you know and that's
all they were talking about on talk
radio and i'm one of those guys once i
see it it's [ __ ] horrific i know i
don't want to hear about it anymore
i don't want to know the kid's name and
know what his face looks like just in
case he's trying to get famous i just
you know
it's just [ __ ] awful right but all i
could listen to on the radio that's all
they were talking about and these
[ __ ] people calling in every goddamn
one of them is just saying the same
[ __ ] thing
over and over again it's like who
doesn't know that it's terrible who
doesn't know that it's
not a tragedy who isn't going to send
prayers
out to the [ __ ] family why do they
gotta keep calling up
this [ __ ] guy calling up you know uh
i believe in a heaven
i believe in a hell and uh this guy
he's uh he's see though if i if i was
running things he would definitely shut
that we got it
the [ __ ] are you calling up for i don't
know it just [ __ ] it became annoying
after a while
and and then the talk show host just
wanting to keep it going
there was like no other way to say it
was a tragedy and he just kept piling us
uh it's bad for uh families it's bad for
it's bad for the nation the freedoms
that we uh we we give people
then the nra always has to immediately
pile on after somebody uses a gun
like this doesn't mean the gun did it
gun didn't do it person did it just just
let you know just in case you thought an
inanimate object could somehow do [ __ ]
on its own
you know and then they always come up
with the brilliant what if everybody had
it was allowed to have a gun then that
wouldn't have happened
yeah i think that that guy would have
killed less people but i think a lot
more other people would have got killed
getting shot in the back of the [ __ ]
head as people tried to shoot
that person right i'm not against guns
by the way but like you know
look everybody can have a driver's
license how many people really are good
at driving
you know what i mean how many people are
good at sports some people have good
hand-eye coordination do you want these
[ __ ] people with guns
and all of a sudden somebody starts
squeezing off some rounds and those
[ __ ] are between you
and the guy shooting at you and you're
not organized at all
you know when when like 10 cops go in
and storm a house they know where the
[ __ ] they're at for a reason so they
don't shoot each other in the back
if you got a bunch of people in a
goddamn movie theater
with [ __ ] glocks and somebody comes
in and starts shooting i mean
it's going to be a [ __ ] it's going to
be even worse
i think what they should do is there's
got to be two
two two levels you have to pass to get a
gun
okay aside from not being a psycho you
should when you get a gun
you should then have to become a [ __ ]
marksman
all right and if you're not a marksman
then it affects the caliber of gun that
you get this actually makes a lot of
sense
all right it's like taking the driver's
test you can't go there blind as a bat
and they just give you a [ __ ]
goddamn car like dude go [ __ ] yourself
go down to
pearl vision and get your game together
they should do the same thing with guns
okay i want to get a gun license well
god bless america you can have one
go over there the gun range and go shoot
at that silhouette over there right
you know if you only hit it once you get
a bb gun
or maybe one of those little toy guns
that that shoots the plastic things you
can still put somebody's eye out though
with it you know
but if you actually go down there and
you're you're a [ __ ]
goddamn maniac right psycho [ __ ]
you know just everything's a head shot
or center mass
then you get the glock
right does that make sense and you just
have a safe word
just something the guy yells when would
[ __ ] like that and everybody hits the
[ __ ] deck
and this guy gets up and just puts two
right in the [ __ ] psycho's head and
it's over
as opposed to just letting everybody
just start [ __ ]
shooting would that make sense
oh if everybody just thought the way i
did the world would be uh
just as [ __ ] up all right um
anyways but what kind of people have to
[ __ ] call up
during a tragedy and you just have to
call up and you just have to reiterate
that it was a [ __ ] tragedy
you have to call up and say that i think
this guy's going to hell like
who doesn't think that you know
[ __ ] idiots watching this [ __ ]
politicians
stammering through so you know family is
the uh
wealth department yes we got it it's
[ __ ] horrible
just get on with punishing this guy go
hang that guy by his [ __ ] toes
they won't they're gonna go through some
big nine [ __ ] year
trial with this guy and then they try to
like they try to blame guns so they try
to blame the [ __ ] movie and just like
he's out of his [ __ ] i can guarantee
before you waste all this money
doing all of these studies this guy is
out of his [ __ ] mind
who who the [ __ ] are going to do
something like that now i'm doing see
we'll see what i'm doing right now
i'm doing what these callers are doing
all right let's plow ahead here how the
[ __ ] is it 38 minutes in
this is the tragic monday morning we're
just gonna talk about tragedies one
after another i'll try to somehow
find something mildly amusing and all of
this [ __ ] all right
um advertisement number two
gamefly.com everybody gamefly offers
over 8 000 video games you can sends the
discs in the mail to you and you can
send it back when you're done playing
the games you like video games want to
be nice to have 8 000 of them
there's no late fees no hassles with
access to all the new releases
works for your playstation nintendo
xbox and now your pc for xbox listeners
only you get a free 15 day two try
do disc trial 22.95 value if you go to
my website
uh podcast page and click the game fly
banner or go to www.gamefly.com
what is that for listeners for my
listeners only
okay for my listeners only you get it
all right
i thought it said for xbox players only
i was like why did they do that
no it's for my listeners only
www.gamefly.com all right
and the uh what do we got here the last
one here
um number three amazon.com you guys know
the deal all right if you're going to
amazon.com just stop by my podcast page
first click on the amazon
banner you don't have to do anything
after that if you buy something
uh they kick a percentage back to me
doesn't cost anything extra to you
and then i kick 10 percent to the
wounded warriors project
uh i've actually just been kind of
kicking 10 percent of what i'm making on
the podcast to it
and it's been great even though now i'm
on some [ __ ]
you know junk email list i think you
know the second you give any money to
anything then all of a sudden they're
just like we got a loud one
next thing you know you're getting [ __ ]
in the mail about penguins
do you care about this too anybody
um all right so plowing ahead plowing
ahead next uh
advice buddies x what's up billy boy i
need a little
unlicensed of that unlicensed advice
that you've been
doling out i like that this guy said
that this is my unlicensed advice that
you should not listen to
because uh i do not have a degree in
anything
all right i am about
two shades below dr dr
phil that's how bad i am at this okay
that wasn't pumping me up that was
dragging him down uh my friend recently
broke up with a girl he's been dating
for a while and wouldn't and wouldn't
you know it
this girl is the tits i've been friendly
with this guy for almost a year and his
girls
was always with us when we hung out oh
jesus
all right i can tell you right now just
go ahead and bang her and say goodbye to
your friendship
um from the moment i met her i've liked
her and wanted to bang her
oh wait but you just want a [ __ ]
ah dude this is dirty this is dirty
she's the kind of girl i imagine when i
think of a girl i would want to have a
relationship with go
[ __ ] yourself you said you wanted a
banger first are you like some
sadistic guy who just wants to uh [ __ ]
this girl and [ __ ] her better than your
friend
so you can just be behind it going yeah
you like that [ __ ] yeah you like that
you one of those guys he's trying to
paint a good picture here but i'm not
buying it
classy attractive funny the whole
shebang dude right off the bat the first
thing you said was you wanted to bang
her
i don't know you're trying to be funny
i'll give you the benefit of the doubt
let's plow ahead i've even developed
feelings
feelings question mark i know that's gay
[ __ ] you
uh for her see how guys we just can't we
just we're not allowed
i actually like this girl i actually
feel like i could spend like i can't
even
say that without having that ah oh my
god
[ __ ] tone in my voice um
let me see if i can just say it how i
say it i really like this girl i think i
could spend my life with her
okay that just sounded like a bad read
there's no way to say it without being
like i don't just feel like i just
really connect with her
[Laughter]
ah go [ __ ] yourselves uh i've even
developed feelings for her
quickly i liked hanging out with her
whenever she tagged along i never
flirted with her or anything like that
but i did rub her muff under the table
come on dude you're leaving some [ __ ]
out he didn't say that last part but
come on
but we did get along pretty well i would
and still do
think about her all the time some real
grade school crush type [ __ ]
now they've broken up and she's single
and ready presumably
to do some revenge banging yeah dude
you're a piece of [ __ ] but god bless you
she was hot enough i'd probably do it no
i wouldn't
my younger days i would i wouldn't
maybe i would i don't know i'm not going
to judge you anyways
see where i'm going with this yeah i saw
we were going with it from the second i
started reading it anyway
unlike most guys i don't want to just
bang this broad i want i want to be with
her
do the whole boyfriend thing but i know
doing so would break one of the most
important rules of male
friendship never [ __ ] your friend's girl
however the power of [ __ ]
has me thinking that's crazy and that
the best and that's the best thing for
me to do
however the power of [ __ ] has me
thinking that's crazy and that the best
thing for me to do
is wait four to six months until things
settle down and see if she feels the
same way that i do
i'm not sure if she will but i'm willing
to try and find out despite the
ramifications
what do i do bill should i go after this
awesome girl risking my friendship
or do i go bros before hoes forget her
and wait for the next [ __ ] du jour uh
or i might just bat [ __ ] crazy
um ah jesus dude like
i can't figure you out you're sitting
here talking like your goo goo gaga and
then you're also just saying like you
just kind of want a banger
all right this is what i'm going to tell
you okay rather than just telling you
i'm going to tell you that this is what
i'm going to tell you before telling you
that
thus eating up more time in this
horrific podcast
um this is the sad thing about getting
older
okay when your friends get older and
they get married
and they have kids you barely see them
anymore it sucks
okay and if they have some if they
married some [ __ ]
douchebag who you know then
and and they just gave their balls away
in the relationship
you're never going to see them again but
if they actually have a cool wife
who lets them go out and hang out with
the fellas you're still only going to
see each other
once in a while you got to raise kids so
in the long run
if you feel like this girl might be the
one you got to do it you can't
you're going to regret it for the rest
of your life but if this is just some
sadistic [ __ ]
where it was she was you just wanted a
banger because she was around
you know and you saw like it's just like
dude i gotta tell you if you bang that
girl and afterwards you're not feeling
anything dude
it's like now
she's got something on you and if she's
a psycho
and if they had a bad breakup you can
better [ __ ] believe
like that's like that's chicks ways of
getting back at guys like they'll go out
and [ __ ] their friends
um i mean just you know you want just
like hell hath no fury
as they say like a woman scorn and if
it's a bad breakup
like women they they want to throw all
your [ __ ] out in the front lawn
light it on fire okay and that's not
enough
to [ __ ] go after your material things
okay that's what they want to do they
want to leave you with and they don't go
and go bang all your [ __ ] friends
and then let you know about it so then
you lose all your friends
you lose your entire wardrobe you stand
there like a flood victim
just tearing up as it starts to rain as
you stand on the [ __ ]
front porch of some dilapidated [ __ ]
three family house
that's how they want to leave you
they're [ __ ] nuts
some of them okay so
you know the deal dude you're stepping
in [ __ ]
you're looking at a field you know it's
a minefield and you want to walk across
it anyways
because there's a woman at the other
side of it which this is a classic
shakespearean tale about ready to unfold
so and i can say that having never read
shakespeare
i tried to read it it's more complicated
than the bible
um i
you know i don't know dude i don't you
you have to this
you got to figure out where the [ __ ]
you're at with this [ __ ] all right
do you really like this girl do you
really think she's the one
or was she just around long enough that
you just were thinking about her and
you know looking at a tan [ __ ] thighs
or a [ __ ] titties or a goddamn mouth
or something
you're just like everyone would be like
you know and you just sat there doing
that the whole [ __ ] time
there always is that excitement that all
your guy friends have when you break up
with a hot girl because they're all like
oh god i always wanted to [ __ ] that girl
jesus christ right and you guys have
that conversation with each other and
that's how you [ __ ] talk like a bunch
of pirates
you said hey do you hear uh mike and
joanne broke up can you believe that
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy
and then you guys sit there and then
there's that half second pause and you
both just start laughing
because you know like dude we can't we
can't oh geez i would love to
i would love to yeah i won't say
anything you don't [ __ ] say anything
it's just it's [ __ ] brutal
it's brutal and then the guy's all
insecure because this is the
the bottom line is if you know that's
why you don't bring your girl around
you don't bring your girl around because
you do it enough your guy friends are
going to want to [ __ ] her
you know and then she kind of gets to
know them and then
did you already do that stupid [ __ ]
phone call when you call
hey you know just calling up just to say
i'm sorry
you guys broke up i thought you guys
look great together
blah blah blah blah and try to catch her
in that weak [ __ ] moment
did you do that your predator
ah we all have um that is a shitstorm
sir
there's no uh there's no way out of that
um
and there's no way you're gonna wait six
to eight months because if the girl's
hot enough in six to eight months she's
already gonna have somebody else
and if you come back around again it's
gonna be like her going backwards
so there see what i did i just lit a
candle under your ass to go [ __ ] do
it
oh gives a [ __ ] let me know how it works
out uh advice
friend's girlfriend is a [ __ ] haven't i
already given advice over this thing
i've given this advice a zillion [ __ ]
times i'm a high school senior and in
three weeks
with me uh in three weeks me and my
friends are going backpacking through
australia for a month and a half
we've been planning this trip since
middle school and i have saved for the
past five years because i am paying for
my share of the trip myself
we're both psyched to graduate from high
school and for this trip dude i hope you
have the most
the only way i would backpack through
australia is if they made
thigh high hooker [ __ ] snake boots
they got like some of the deadliest
snakes on the planet
they got that taipan where the [ __ ] it
is they got the uh no they got black
mambas out there
those ones you get bit like in the
second it registered
the pain of getting bit you like
collapse
yeah [ __ ] all that all right dude we'll
have fun with that
this sounds like one of those trips
where somebody ends up dying and then
somebody goes on trial for possibly
murdering the other person and then they
get off
and then but there's always that
wonderment of what really happened
whenever americans go to australia
somebody dies
remember that guy was on the honeymoon
he went scuba diving
and his uh wife got eaten by a shark
you remember that one or something weird
or they went deep sea uh
[ __ ] snorkeling i'm gonna tell you
right now if you're a [ __ ] woman
and uh if you're a lady
um and you're on it you're going on a
honeymoon if it involves [ __ ] scuba
diving
so any any sort of going out to the
ocean
that's it it's over call off the wedding
all right call it off nothing good comes
from that
he's either going to get drunk and fall
overboard or he's going to shut the air
valve off
[Music]
don't go on a cruise you know and if you
do
you do not go up on deck unless there's
plenty of witnesses around
[ __ ] that moonlight kissing [ __ ] all
that that's when you go off the back of
the boat
she was just she wanted to reach down
and touch the water i don't know what
happened
no body no nothing ah [ __ ] that
hey billiam i'm a high school all right
so anyways they're going to australia my
friend and i have known each other since
we were three
and our families are very close he's
like he's like a brother
to me and we've often confided in each
other and asked each other for
relationship advice however recently my
friend has started dating this girl
who has put a huge rift in our
relationship congratulations he's met
his first psycho
you guys are only high school age i
don't think this is going to be that big
a deal the girl my friend is dating is a
total [ __ ]
she's ignorant and jealous and generally
has an unattractive personality they've
only been dating for two months but she
feels like she owns them
she found out that my friend and i were
going on this trip and has been rude to
me ever since
yeah she's insecure she's young
and she's [ __ ] a lot of guys it
stayed it started
with just snipping remarks elevated over
time
blah blah blah this is just gonna be the
usual [ __ ]
the other night we were all at a party
she got hammered she came up to me
started
shoving me and told me that my ghetto
[ __ ] wasn't going to seduce
her boyfriend what this comment probably
had something to do with the fact that
i'm black and her boyfriend is white
though i was seeing red i tried not to
sucker punch that [ __ ] in the face yeah
dude dude don't don't ever do that
uh i've boxed and kicked box for the
past three years and i'm pretty sure i
could have stomped the yard all over uh
yeah dude what the [ __ ] where did that
come from
i think the fact that you're a guy you
could pretty much beat up most women so
which is why you don't do it
you know it's like running up the score
in a college game
um i told her to calm down i have never
done anything with my friend and have no
desire
intentions of anything happen in aussie
land she kept yelling and screaming
and making a scene eventually oh so
she's basically calling you gay
in front of all your friends at a party
and you're at a high school level yeah
that's kind of uh
that's a situation eventually i just
gave up trying to reason with the drunk
broad and i left naturally i told my
friend what she said he agreed it was
absolutely unacceptable and had a talk
with her
that turned into a fight my friend's
girl gave him an ultimate of me or her
and
forbade him from going to australia this
is absolutely hilarious to me which it
should be
since their fight my friend hasn't
called or texted me back
what should i do you know what [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him let him learn the lesson you
know what you do you go down there
with your [ __ ] american accent
all right and you're gonna get more
[ __ ] [ __ ] than you could ever shake
a goddamn stick
a walking stick act all right to keep it
in a hiking sense here
all right [ __ ] him and then you come
back and just you know
let him be with that [ __ ] wash your
[ __ ] hands of it
okay you go invest a lot of time effort
and money into this trip
i'm not going to have the beginning of
my senior year destroyed by some skank
face control freak
lush which you shouldn't but i also
don't want to hurt my friend
and have and have him be miserable when
we're going to be stuck living sleeping
traveling together for six weeks
hey [ __ ] him this is the deal
[ __ ] him [ __ ] him okay he wants to be
with that [ __ ]
let him be with that [ __ ] get on with
your [ __ ] life he wants to go with
you to australia
let him if he doesn't if he wants to
stay back there with that psycho
let him let he has to learn this lesson
the same way
you got to let a toddler [ __ ] slam
his head off the goddamn coffee table to
understand gravity or at least putting
his little fat baby arms out
you know you got you got to let this
dude
fall right on his [ __ ] face all right
let's hope he's wearing a condom but
he's old enough to know how people get
pregnant so
you know give me a [ __ ] break [ __ ]
this [ __ ] alright
that's it [ __ ] him wash your hands of it
it's over all right you go out you enjoy
your senior year
you go to australia he comes he doesn't
you don't give a [ __ ]
all right that's on him he wants to sit
there and invest all his life in some
stupid drunk skank face control freak
lush as you call her let him
what the [ __ ] do you care okay
she [ __ ] embarrassed you i mean you
don't do that
you don't do that i remember one time i
was dating this [ __ ] girl and she was
so [ __ ] rude to one of my friends
and that night i was like i was beside
myself and i was asking her how she
could do something like that and she's
just like
she was just like i'm sorry i didn't
like him and
that was the first time i was just like
is that the most arrogant [ __ ] thing
ever
and i'm not gonna lie to you it took me
like another like uh
week or two but i
from that second on i just [ __ ]
pulled back and i was just like you know
what go [ __ ] yourself
because you know that's the life you're
gonna have you're gonna have no you're
gonna all your friends
are gonna be gone so [ __ ] her all right
did i say it enough time yeah
[ __ ] her um dilemma
um all right number one at their
physical peak would you rather box
laila ali or will smith
uh will smith there's no winning with
laila ali i either lose to a check or
beat one up
that was easy i'll fight will smith
worst i can do is lose to an actor
but he used to rap but he was mainstream
rap right
but what was the ones that he had
what the [ __ ] what was that i know
people always talk about that summertime
one i don't remember how that one went
i was too busy listening to metal what
the [ __ ] did he have back then parents
just don't under don't understand
that's when like mainstream white people
were finally discovering rap that's what
we did we
parents just don't understand can't
touch this
the worst of the worst but go [ __ ]
yourself
african americans all right i bet the
first white music you listened to was it
was
it was awful huh with your hall and oats
um anyways uh if if you were a parent of
a boy and a girl
would you rather see your son on to
catch a predator
jesus being nationally exposed as a
pedophile or be driving down the street
and see your daughter
out on the corner whoring yourself out
as a prostitute
ah prostitute prostitute
yeah prostitute there's nothing worse
than [ __ ] a kid
you know i don't think it should change
the outcome of who won a football game
uh but that's just me uh overrated
underrated
underrated uh scabies
is underrated a great reason
to launder i don't know what the [ __ ]
that means i don't know what scabies it
would launder what money
your clothes i don't know what you're
saying there number two pointing out
did i even pronounce that correctly um
two pointing out details about a steamy
sex story
that make it uncomfortable and unsexy
jesus christ what the [ __ ] is this creep
for example hey baby remember the other
day when i bent you over
the dining room chair and we raw dogged
it and you finished me off
on your knees between the cat food
dishes and the litter box
your girlfriend expression will change
from sexy to
horrified in zero to sixty um
if you're the woman who's dating that
guy please break up with that [ __ ]
reptilian psycho um is that the podcast
for this week uh we're coming up on it
we are coming up on it oh you know what
i forgot i forgot to do the classic
stamp star calm read
hey everybody
oh wait what am i thinking i i got to do
this other one legal zoom
i forgot about this one this is a new
advertiser yeah they can be pissed
58 minutes into the podcast is there any
way you could read it a little earlier
um 58 minutes in all right legal zoom
everybody uh you probably heard about
legalzoom.com and i've probably seen it
there on a bunch of youtube videos but
now i'm telling you about them so you
got to check them out these guys are
great
all right um because i've actually done
half the [ __ ] that they do here and i
paid a [ __ ]
lawyer to do it it cost me a zillion
dollars um
all right if you basically are you
sitting in a cubicle
right now are you wondering why you're
making somebody else's dream come true
why you're working towards that when you
actually have an idea for a business
you know well and you're sitting there
going well i'd love to get myself
incorporated to start my business but
it's going to cost a fortune
well at legalzoom.com if you've been
waiting for the perfect time to start
your dream business
um right now is the time to do it you
can incorporate your business
or form an llc at legalzoom.com
starting at just 99 bucks it costs me
like 1500
something like that 700 1500 i can't
remember it's a lot of money
they'll do it for 99 bucks and if you
have a family
um you need to make sure that they're
protected legalzoom also
will help you uh make out your last will
and testament for just 69 bucks
that's something that i have to do all
right
i have to make up my last will and
testament which is really
a scary thing for me to do you know
because you're actually dealing with
your own mortality
and considering i just had a dream like
i did last night it freaks me out but i
got to tell you
if i'm going to do it i'm doing it for
69 bucks
um in the past 12 years over 2 million
americans have used legalzoom
for llc's wills trusts trademarks and
more this is basically look if you're
trying to start a business
or if you need a will to protect your
assets this is the place to go
uh you're gonna save hundreds even
thousands of dollars versus going to
traditional route and i know what you're
thinking well what if i get bogged down
what if i can't figure it out they even
have an attorney to help you if you need
uh
if you need help basically they have
attorneys that you can call and that
type of stuff all right
mandatory close sorry no one's
the worst there's the mandatory close
everybody to this ad
start your business and protect your
family today at legalzoom.com you can
also get a special discount
from listening to this podcast make sure
you enter bur b-u-r-r in the referral
box and check out
uh at checkout for more savings
legalzoom
is not a law firm and self-help services
are provided
at your direction
all right so that's the deal there it is
you want to start your business you want
to be incorporated
that is the cheapest most efficient way
to do it uh i wish they were around back
when i got incorporated i could have
saved myself hundreds of dollars
so there you go legalzoom what else was
there anything else i wanted to talk
about
um i don't think there was
stamps.com stamps.com you got that one
down by now huh
if you don't want to go to the post
office anymore you want to be able to
weigh packages and print your own legal
stamps
off your computer and printer in your
own damn apartment at any hour of the
day
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
in the corner
and uh you get a 105 dollar
bonus offer free shipping and all that
type is our free stamps
you're all over it look at me just
saving your money
i got you a way to start your own damn
business make your last will and
testament
bring the post office into your
apartment 8 000 video games in there
and help out the wounded warriors what
more do you need
what more do we need bill we'd like one
more funny [ __ ] story from you
to end the podcast all right let's see
what i got wasn't enough that i said
bye-bye to somebody in a wheelchair
jesus christ if i went to church how
many [ __ ] hail mary's is that you
know something i should go to confession
and just tell that story just to see
what the guy says
you know because i think they just make
that stuff up
to our fathers hail mary's
back there drinking out of a chalice
who did that first those rappers in
atlanta or priests
well i guess hip-hop's only been around
since what did i just say hip-hop i
think it did
since when when did that actually come
about was it in the early 70s
is that what it was number one run dmc
actually said that walk this way was the
first
rap remember that
why did they say that you know
did they run out of leather jacket uh
shell toes was that was that fun running
low when they actually said that that
wasn't the first rap
why would they say that did black people
get mad at them when they said that [ __ ]
now gives a [ __ ] you know what people i
don't think i have anything left
i was actually hoping that the red sox
were going to be in town tonight because
i wanted to uh
to head down there um even though i'm
not drinking
i really want to drink i ain't going a
lot of people i really want to drink
i do i haven't drank in a couple of
weeks
drying myself out you know while i get
through the uh the kids show
that i'm gonna be doing here you gotta
be knowing at this point that i'm not
doing a [ __ ] kids show
as i'm sitting here talking about
pedophiles saying bye-bye to somebody in
a wheelchair
and saying that joe paterno's wins
should still count
in case your detective work he was still
questioning whether or not i'm actually
going to be hosting some sort of revamp
of a kid show
uh it ain't happening uh i actually got
another acting gig
i'm doing all right i'm doing all right
on the all the old acting gigs things
this is what this is perfect it's the
exact
[ __ ] reason why i moved out to la i
just wanted to start getting some
parts and some [ __ ] you know that's all
i wanted to do
i don't need to be a star i just want to
i just want to be in a
just let me shoot a gun get shot to
something
you know i told you guys my acting these
are these are my acting goals i want to
do that scene
where you run down the alley and you're
getting chased by a cop and you get to
the chain-link fence and you get like
three [ __ ]
crawls up it and they drag you back down
i want to do that
i want to get interrogated i want to get
shot
i'm going to get blown away i want to
get killed by a monster
at some point i want to be getting eaten
or something just be going
that's all i want to do all right
i don't want to do gorillas in the mist
what the [ __ ] are they counting down out
there i think these are like coast guard
people learning how to be coast guard
people outside this
hang on what am i doing
hang on hang on hang on hang on i think
it's some sort of coast guard training
thing out there
ten nine eight you always know when you
bought someone in boston when they get
down to four
six five four
i actually heard somebody say bane this
day i got breakfast you want some
bananas with that
uh no i don't trying to cut down on the
cobs
all right that's the podcast for this
week um
go [ __ ] yourselves don't take any [ __ ]
and uh you know i obviously wasn't you
know
uh who gives a [ __ ] i'm not gonna sit
there and even try what am i doing i
just said i wasn't gonna apologize for
anything
[ __ ] penn state's wins should count
all right
those [ __ ] players played the goddamn
games they blew out their knees
they risked [ __ ] injury they won the
goddamn games all right
just cause some old [ __ ] was doing some
[ __ ] that he should be burned in the
street for you shouldn't punish those
[ __ ] kids
i hope penn state sells out all their
[ __ ] games
you know learn from smu
all right everybody just walk the [ __ ]
away you show up in force
that'd be the greatest [ __ ] thing you
know how how unbelievable
if you want to somehow turn this [ __ ]
thing around penn state
fans is if every game over the next four
years
sells out even if you lose every [ __ ]
game
okay there's no other program out there
could ever question
your loyalty that would be the greatest
example of uh
fan support unlike these some of these
[ __ ] red sox fans out here
48 and 48 they're [ __ ] walking away
you know see that's the deal with most
fans they're not real fans
you know you're like a marriage in
sickness and in health good times and
bad it doesn't work that way the fans
fans basically say i love you
until you suck and then i'm walking away
i'm gonna leave you when you need me
most just like that kenny rogers song
four hundred children cropping the
field five has a bad time
we won 48 games the lost 48 games
and now you're leaving you [ __ ]
you know what get the [ __ ] out god bless
john lester i know he doesn't want to
lose
i love him pedroia when when we're
[ __ ] down like that and he's [ __ ]
pounding him on the leg trying to get
him psyched up i love that [ __ ]
i love that as much as watching him win
all right and if you're walking away now
you're a [ __ ] and as tom cruise said in
[ __ ] taps take off that beret
right poor tom cruise
his [ __ ] lady left them i like
everybody like comes down on scientology
you know what i mean what's the [ __ ]
problem with it until they have like a
uh uh inquisition i really don't think
they're anywhere as bad as my
[ __ ] religion you know what i mean we
had like 58 sandusky's running around
doing that [ __ ]
did they did was the catholic church not
allowed to go to a bowl game
did they take away some of jesus's
miracles they didn't
those [ __ ] games count now i'm
screaming in a hotel room
those [ __ ] games count those kids won
those games those games count i did
stand up
for the penn state nittany lions when
they came out and they did they were
playing usc in the rose bowl i did stand
up for them
and they they were [ __ ] it was like
performing for the troops high and tight
everybody listening
i didn't have a great set nobody heckled
me they were great great bunch of guys
you're going to punish them
go [ __ ] yourself all right this is what
i say if you take away penn state's
victories
then you have to take away jesus's
miracles jesus miracles didn't count
if penn state's victories don't come
that's what i'm saying that's my
statement i'm sticking to it
go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week
you